[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a korean thriller film
called everyone is there
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
lisa is a timid and shy 16 year old in
the opening scene she is running down a
hill in the middle of the woods her
clothes are torn and her face is covered
in injuries suddenly she trips on a
stair and falls several feet below with
her remaining strength she begs someone
for help and falls unconscious in the
following scene lisa is in the hospital
the severity of her injuries is clearly
visible in broad daylight fortunately a
bypasser found her in the woods and
brought her to the hospital outside two
police officers are discussing the case
judging by the previous bullying reports
the cops are sure that lisa was bullied
by the girls of her school but before
advancing the case they will have to get
an official statement from lisa they
have also tried to contact lisa's
parents but it turns out that her mother
died a few years ago and her father is
overseas he is not involved in her life
and doesn't care even if she dies when
she regains consciousness the head
police detective mr kim introduces
himself he asks her several questions
about her health and the incident that
happened yesterday but lisa remains
quiet throughout the interrogation they
are interrupted by her homeroom teacher
miss lee she urges the officer to go
away and let the girl rest for a while
malice is clear in her intention when
she tries to stop lisa from giving away
who actually did this to her mr kim then
notices three middle-aged women in the
doorway they are the mothers of the
girls who are suspected of bullying lisa
he figures that they want to threaten
lisa or bribe her into not saying
anything he asks them to go away since
they are legally not allowed to meet the
victim but the women are persistent
their husbands are people with power and
money which makes them believe their
daughters can get away with anything mr
kim states that their daughters were the
ones who called lisa to the mountain but
the mothers nonchalantly claim that the
girls were just hanging out when the
argument gets heated lisa asks them to
go away because she wants to rest after
the incident the homeroom teacher miss
lee meets the school principal both of
them know very well that lisa was
bullied to save the school's reputation
the principal wants miss lee to transfer
lisa to another school when she returns
he hides his corruption by pretending to
be worried about the bully's future a
few weeks later lisa recovers from the
injuries and can finally walk around mr
kim has tried to ask her about the
incident several times in the past week
but lisa has yet to break her silence
due to lack of proper evidence the case
is handed to some counseling guidance
teacher and the bullies are let free
again one night lisa lets negative
thoughts get the best of her she tries
to commit the unthinkable but has to
stop when a lady walks into her room the
lady is the counseling guidance teacher
miss so me so me has seen a lot of
students like lisa and helped them live
after being traumatized by similar
incidents she isn't like any normal
guidance teacher she was also bullied in
school and knows how it feels to be weak
hence she helps her students take
revenge on the bullies initially she
doesn't seem to feel sorry for lisa she
makes her remember the events of the
night which in turn makes lisa break
down crying when she calms down somi
asks her to stay alive until she returns
again on the day lisa is being
discharged she is visited by the leader
of the bullies nyan she has brought her
new school uniform knowing that her old
one is torn the girl shows no remorse
for almost killing lisa and tells her
she's better off dead before leaving she
also threatens her to stay away from the
police after she leaves so me enters the
room having heard the entire
conversation she brings lisa to her
house and helps her settle in after that
lisa goes to the neighborhood where her
mother used to live before her death she
is reminiscing about her past when a
passerby catches her attention she
follows the girl and soon finds out that
she is her identical twin jenny lisa
tries to reunite with her but jenny
walks away uninterested it is revealed
that the girl's parents got divorced
before they were born the couple was not
on good terms so the father never wanted
anything to do with lisa and jenny but
with time the mother's financial
condition got weaker hence she left lisa
at her father's home and started living
with jenny the sisters never met after
the incident and lisa had to live with
her father who thought of her as a
burden the next day so me follows jenny
to a convenience store and notices her
shoplifting she stops her outside and
asks her for help even when told that
her sister was almost bullied to death
jenny remains uninterested in the
conversation she only agrees to help
when somi offers her money in the
evening the three meet at somi's house
she suggests they live together for a
week or so until the plan comes to a
conclusion jenny is not a fan of the
idea but agrees to do it anyway but then
she is told that she will have to go to
school as lisa to teach the bullies a
lesson jenny dropped out of school a
year ago to her no amount of money is
worth going to school again she refuses
to cooperate and storms out of the
apartment a few minutes later she
receives a video in a group chat the
video is of lisa getting bullied a group
of girls tear her clothes shove her to
the ground and kick her repeatedly while
a girl with an obnoxious laugh films
everything this makes jenny so mad that
she returns to the apartment and calls
lisa a coward the video reminds lisa of
the traumatic night and makes her
hyperventilate seeing her twin in such a
condition jenny cannot help but feel bad
for her with much determination she asks
somi where she can find the girl with
the obnoxious laugh the following day
she goes to school as lisa her
classmates notice the evident change in
her behavior but no one pays much
attention to her that is until the group
of bullies enters the classroom the
bully nyon excitedly sits on jenny's
table and calls her cute for returning
to school because of her laugh jenny
realizes that nyon is the girl in the
video and the one who made everyone else
bully lisa when the bully starts getting
handsy jenny slaps her to the ground
with a single blow she then grabs her by
the hair and sits on top of her asking
her to laugh again following that she
shoots a video of her while choking her
simultaneously her bully friends can do
nothing but retreat in fear they only
stop when miss lee interferes she takes
them to a private room to discipline
them but jenny isn't someone who obeys
teachers when she and miss lee are alone
she approaches her with a pen subtly
threatening to stab her miss lee
stammers in fear as jenny calls her out
for being unfair to lisa later that day
jenny returns home and shows lisa the
video of nyan lisa doesn't know how to
feel about it because she doesn't
support violence even when it's
projected towards her biggest bully somi
warns jenny to not do anything of such
sort again because it might get her
sister in trouble she should have seen
the stabby pen scene the next day is the
twins birthday they get themselves a
cake and bond for the first time in
their lives lisa tells jenny how hard
her life has been because she never got
any kind of love from her parents jenny
sympathizes with her since life in
poverty with her mother has also not
been ideal the next morning jenny is
asleep so lisa decides to go to school
on her own she believes that since nyan
was taught a lesson she won't mess with
her again at school nyan's mother is
with the principal discussing a way to
transfer lisa to another school the
woman is afraid that she will try to
take revenge on her daughter and wants
her gone as soon as possible a corrupt
principle assures her they will take
care of the situation meanwhile lisa
overhears their conversation from the
doorway and runs to the bathroom in
tears there she bumps into nyeon before
locking herself inside a stall nyan who
has been wanting to take revenge dumps a
bucket of water on her oh snap lisa
returns home wet and falls to the ground
in exhaustion somi helps her while jenny
glows red in anger she immediately calls
nion and asks her to come to the
mountain if she doesn't want the video
of her beating up lisa on the internet
scared to be convicted of bullying nyan
does as told when she reaches the
mountain jenny hits her on the head and
knocks her out upon regaining
consciousness she finds her hands and
legs tied and her mouth taped jenny
removes the tape from her mouth and
forcefully makes her drink a full bottle
of water then she brings out another
bottle filled with acid nion cries for
her life which only makes jenny laugh
harder she pours the acid dangerously
close to her face but promises not to
kill her by now nyan can hardly breathe
and is crying hysterically jenny unties
her legs and tells her to run away if
she wants to stay alive the bully takes
the chance but falls a few meters away
just then lisa arrives at the scene and
tries to free nyon because she doesn't
want any more people to get hurt seconds
later somi follows and is shocked at the
scene she scolds jenny for losing her
temper and calls an ambulance for nion
in the following scene jenny is getting
interrogated by the police since no one
actually saw her with the victim she is
only a suspect so me arrives and asks
the officers to let her go for the time
being the officers decide to wait until
nion gains consciousness and lets them
go outside jenny claims that she does
not regret her actions in the least and
would do it again if she had the chance
a disappointed so me leaves her alone
and returns home right after nion's
mother attacks jenny calling her names
jenny smugly mocks the lady and asks her
to laugh like her daughter while arguing
she also slips that what she did was
only a payback the officers realize that
she is in fact the culprit when mr kim
calls her by lisa's name she lashes out
and claims that the lisa he is looking
for is at home later mr kim and his
fellow officer are driving back home but
kim cannot get the thought of jenny out
of his mind he has also noticed a
significant change in her behavior since
she was in the hospital suspecting that
she has a doppelganger he drives to her
house to check however on reaching the
place he finds it empty just then he
gets a call from the hospital informing
him that nion has gained consciousness
she is blabbering about someone else
being on the scene when she was attacked
a flashback shows us that jenny was
alone when nion was lying on the ground
in the mountains in fact jenny lisa and
so me are all the same person till now
every time lisa was talking to either of
them she was only talking to herself she
never had a twin sister after being
bullied she was so alone and stranded
that she fantasized about having someone
who cared for her soon the fantasy
changed into obsessiveness and she
developed a multiple personality
disorder meanwhile so me is a guidance
officer and the only person who helped
lisa but she never met lisa at the
hospital lisa imagined her being there
to tackle loneliness and eventually
added her to her personalities the court
finds out what exactly is wrong with
lisa and she ends up in therapy she
drops out of school and focuses on her
mental health we see a clip of her
talking to a therapist about her past
trauma in great detail she has finally
healed from it in the last scene the
real so me drops her at the airport lisa
is flying to a different city to start a
new life subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching